hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the Paul
Morphy saga and we are back at the first
American chess congress this is the
semi-finals
poor Charles Murphy with the black piece
against the other lifts and hind we
already checked out one game against
listen line we're live behind where more
if we had the white pieces and he went
for the Evans gambit and there is also
one other friendly game that was
recorded before but I decided not sure
that one is it's really too short and
really just too brutal were Morphy win
for the Kings gambit and a listen high
against again lost but these are now
important games these are part of the
first American chess congress so let's
see what leaked online can do with the
white pieces so more feet versus lift
and height and in the other parts of the
semi-final Louis Paulson the faces
dr. Benjamin Rafael we'll see how that
goes and who will meet in the finals so
littenheim
opens with E 4 we have E 5 9 f3 Knight
to c6 and Bishop to c4 the Italian game
is on the board and here we have Knight
to f6
we have d4 not going for knight Knight
to g5 but you know what what can you do
so d4 and it captures on d4 and now II
five and a lion is still being played
today and there's a lot of theory behind
it of course but in those days there
really wasn't a lot of theory about it
so here if you're not well versed in you
know theory and openings and stuff you
might go something like Knight to g4 and
after castles if you recapture the pony
you might easily lose a piece here just
a rookie one attacks the night and you
cannot move the knight if you defend it
f4 just wins the night so of course a
Morphy not about to do something like
that he goes d5 it is the strongest move
still to this day Bishop to b5 pinning
the night and now Knight to e4 and here
Knight captures on d4 so this is all
still played today we have Bishop to d7
and now at Knight captures in c6 r today
you would definitely see Bishop captures
and c6 not not a knight captures because
this is just well loses loses time
be captures and c6 morphia replies the
bishop has to go back Bishop to d3 and
now more if he finds an interesting way
on how to win the bishop pair he plays
Bishop to c5 now threatens to pick up
the F do pawn and you have to play
Bishop captures any four there really is
no move for you to play if you try
something like Bishop to e3 to keep the
bishops on the board it doesn't really
work because after Bishop captures you
still have to give up the light square
Bishop here because if you capture just
Queen h4 and white is completely busted
just g3 Knight characters here and there
is no move for white so after Bishop to
c5 Bishop captures on e4
now Burlington hide in the now not D
captures but first Queen to h4 again
Morphy threatens maid and he wants to
recapture with the Queen so he doesn't
mess up his pawn structure so a Quinta e
- not allowing the Queen to capture here
and now d captures on e4 and now again
what do you play here oh if nothing goes
for Bishop to e3 a safer idea was just
castling yes this pawn is a little bit
weak but even if morphe goes after it
right away you can play Knights to be -
you go after the e4 pawn and the game
continues however listen time listen
honey went for Bishop to e3
I just attack more fees Bishop here and
allow the Morphy a nice in-between move
and I situation took Bishop to g4 now
the queen is under attack and there
isn't all that much you can do here the
the sturdiest defense is g3 just
offering a queen trait so after morphe
goes Queen to h5 now you go Queen to c4
you attack the bishop and of course if
the bishop moves you have Queen captures
with check picking up the look but
luckily for for black morphe has a rook
to b8 here which threatens mate and now
you have to defend Knight to be two and
only now Bishop captures on e3f captures
on e3 and not just castles and black is
of course much better here so even even
with best defense such as g3 least in
hinds position is is very difficult to
play so Queen to c4 instead he doesn't
see this g3 idea
he sees it that maybe he just doesn't
see that it could become very
complicated or who knows what could
happen so instead he just goes for a
double attack against the bishop and if
more if he captures then he still has
Queen captures on c6 but interestingly
this is exactly what morphe does he
plays Bishop captures and III and the
morphe offers the c6 upon upon here with
check now the thing is if you go after
this you're not actually winning the
rule because Queen is seven now the rook
is defended by the h8 rook so Queen
captures and c7 King to f8 and now after
one more check King g8 you don't really
have a way to get out of this mess you
still cannot capture the bishop you
could you could castle here but even if
you Castle black is still completely
winning even feel free to pause the
video in this high potato hypothetical
situation and try to find the winning
move for black while I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on either
finding rook to b8 this is of course a
very useful move first you bring the
rook but then now I pretty much just
continues but the move I wanted you to
find was just Bishop captures and f2
with checked as it's much more forcing
rook captures and d3 our rule goes back
just e to the Queen covers d1 square so
you'd have to go here then another Queen
comes into the game so here you would
have to give up the lock 92 and then
after captures captures with the rook
now you go roof to d8 and it's pretty
much the same thing now if the Queen
moves the night falls unless the Queen
goes to c7 and threatens mate but still
rook to d7 you just block mate and after
Queen seed check now you bring back the
Queen and White has nothing to do black
is just up a whole rook so that's what
happens if Queen captures and c6 very
exciting stuff so g3 was played here
leaving more feet with the option from
the thumbnail and just going after this
Queen to d8 to d1 idea but there was
also another interesting idea can you
pause the video and transporta tried to
play in even greater style than morphe
if such a thing is possible well they
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations
and finding even a more stylish move
than the one morphe plate and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show a
queenside castle here is just beautiful
as of course you cannot capture the
Queen because of rook to d1 mate
and it's not it's not all that easy to I
had to defend for example you could give
a little check here Queenie six checking
b8 and now you have to develop the night
tonight c3 to defend mate okay now the
recovers the d1 square but now Queen h3
and it's it's just a very very difficult
to get out it's not very difficult it's
impossible for example if you captured a
bishop just queen g2 attacks the rook
and there's also mate and e2 coming so
not nothing you can do here so that's
one of the one of the options that were
possible this queenside castle here
after g3 but more if he goes for the
more straightforward one Queen to d8
going for Queen to deep sorry for Queen
to be one checkmate
and the problem is now you cannot play
Knight to c3 yes you no longer are
getting checkmated with via the d1
square but you're getting Queen D future
King F 1 and Queen captures and f2 mate
so there's that
so after Queen to d8 well what can you
do
you could Castle but it's just it's just
pretty much the same as resigning as
you're still down a piece so f captures
and III was played but now you allow
more feet Queen to d1 with check King f2
and Queen to f3 with check so you have
to play something you have to go down
with the rook better better to g1 as at
least from g1 you guard the h1 rook so
King the g1 was played but now more
features goes Bishop to h3 and now
there's a the threat of checkmate on g2
not much you can do here leave behind
tried Queen captures in seasick was c6
with check King to f8 and now Queen
captures an a8 with check morphe said ok
King the e7 I offer yet another rook but
then after that there is no defense
against Queen to G to mate and of course
we can hein nudists and it was in this
position unmoved 19 the
Theodore littenheim resigned in the game
and game one from the American chess
Congress first American chess Congress
the semifinals goes to Paul Morphy we'll
see we'll see what happens next in the
match so really a really exciting stuff
and you can see that they're playing
lines that there are played even today
and they just take you know a detour
somewhere somewhere dark where no one in
the right mind would go today but that's
why games are so interesting and they
only last 19 moves but yeah yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Christian job jobs
Louise Donovan Frederick Verner Andrew
Klein and Jennifer Anderson for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video Sarah
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the Paul Morphy saga
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chest world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day